to be branded a racist is the worst
possible label that you can be stuck
with in america in 2021 and i've got bad
news
for my paler listeners if you are a
white person
you are a racist so pronounceth
the left-wing commentator mark lamont
hill to my friend liz wheeler
do you i mean do you believe that do you
believe all white people are inherently
racist
so i i don't know if you're backing me
into a corner with that question but yes
i i do
uh yes yes i do and he'll hill is not
alone in calling all white people racist
this sort of a smear is accepted as
common knowledge in classrooms
in corporations in just about every
other institution
in this country meanwhile a former doj
official
accidentally admits that the federal
bureaucracy has a lot more power to spy
on you
than it has acknowledged and uses that
power the fbi arrests larpers with lego
sets
and still the liberal establishment
wants you to believe
that the greatest threat to our country
is coming from the right
i'm michael knowles it's the michael
knowles show
[Music]
my favorite comment friday comes from
the spanish inquisition
the the inquisition states speechless is
like the illegitimate child
of the new york times their actions have
brought it about
and now they refuse to acknowledge it
that is true the book is in no small
part about the new york times
and the sort of way that they manipulate
language and
and the times is just a stand-in for all
of these other leftist institutions
so no wonder they don't want to put it
on the list but i really appreciate all
of you who have sent
speechless to the top spot on the actual
bestseller lists appreciate that you
know
a lot of people are trying to spy
on you to get your data in and out of
the government so if you want to
avoid that sort of unpleasantness i'd
recommend start mail
free email services like big tech email
providers are not
really free you pay with your privacy
and since those companies have access to
every email you send and receive
big tech can sell your data to the
highest bidder which is why i would
strongly recommend
start mail to secure your email start
mail keeps my email private every email
is encrypted
even if the recipient doesn't use
encryption which means big tech cannot
read or scan or analyze or sell
my personal information ever with start
mail deleted means
deleted when you delete an email it's
gone forever
and start mail uses their own servers
not big text servers
which means they can't be put out of
business start mail
is also backed by the most stringent
privacy laws in the world
you get unlimited anonymous aliases so
when you're giving your email to a
company but you want to protect your
identity
startmail can generate a shareable alias
email so people can't sell your
information
and they can be deleted any time
i would not recommend that you trust big
tech you should not do that
start securing your email privacy with
start mail sign up day you get 50
off your first year go to start mail.com
knowles that is start mail with a t
s-t-a-r-t mail.com knowles 50
off your first year start mail.com
knowles
all whites are racist says not just mark
lamont hill but
so virtually every major power
center in our society is pushing to some
degree
this kind of a lie it the way they do it
by the way
there is a very clever way that they do
it and it actually does tie in with
speechless which is the left has just
redefined racism so
a definition of racism that we would all
probably accept is if you hate other
people
on the basis of their race you just you
just hate blacks you just hate italians
you just ate whatever
the left has redefined racism they have
first
redefined racism such that black people
cannot be racist
by their new definition so they'll say
racism is racial hatred
combined with power and they define
power as only being held by white people
so they're by definition then black
people can't be racist
but then they'll go even further this
was one of the innovations of this guy
ibram kendy who is a total huckster he's
a pseudo-academic
who has fake degrees and fake discipline
i guess they're real degrees
in fake academic disciplines who has
become very wealthy and very prominent
by by selling this lie
of the difference between racism and
anti-racism and not racism he's just a
race hustler but what he is saying is
if you admit that you're a racist you're
a racist but if you do not admit that
you're a racist
then you're definitely a racist the very
heartbeat
of racism is denial and the sound of
that heartbeat that the individual makes
is i'm not racist that's the sound of
that heartbeat
of which is denial which is the the very
heart of racism
this is an effective rhetorical trick i
don't want to say that it's clever
because i don't think it's that clever i
think in a prior age when people were
less stupid and more
more educated better educated they would
have been able to see through this kind
of a rhetorical trick
but today we can't really what ebram
candy is doing
is it's called begging the question
sometimes people use that phrase beg the
question as if it means to raise a
question that's not what it means
it's a technical term it means to assume
your own conclusion
and so what ibram candy is doing is he's
saying
that all white people are racist that's
where he's ending and that's where he's
beginning
and the evidence of this because the the
counter example would be what about the
white people who say they're not racist
he says
to say that you're not racist is even
further proof that you are a racist
because because admission means you're
racist and denial also means you're
racist so it's completely unfalsifiable
there's no way to get around it
i mention all these guys mark lamont
hill ibram kendy and the
countless blue checkmarks and
establishmentarians
who who espouse this kind of vile stuff
that all whites are racist and don't
forget racist is the worst thing you can
be called so what they're really saying
is whites are just
all terrible terrible people
because all those guys are on twitter
all those all of them are permitted on
twitter they are permitted in the
mainstream discourse which brings me
to twitter's decision last week to ban
this
right-wing 22 year old nick fuentes
nick fuentes was banned now by the way i
should point out
i don't call the guy a conservative this
guy fuentes fuentes himself says
i'm not a conservative i'm much more
radical than that i
and he engages more in identitarian type
of politics
doesn't really matter twitter bans this
guy
because a left-wing group pressures him
too and there are currently two
opinions about this that are really
mainstream the first opinion is
nick fuentes has said terrible things
and as a matter of principle
he should be kicked off of twitter and
all the rest of the platforms
that's the first opinion the second
opinion is nick fuentes has said
terrible things
but as a matter of principle anyone
should be able to say whatever they want
and he shouldn't have been kicked off of
twitter or any other platform
i do not agree with either of those
views
what worries me about the nick fuentes
ban
has very little to do with him it has to
do
with the sort of actions that our
establishment our institutions and our
government is taking
this guy he is a 22 year old who has
said lots of things that lots and lots
of people object to
he has been kicked off of every social
media platform every major social media
platform he has reportedly been banned
from every
major financial institution and he's
been placed on the no-fly list
without being charged with a crime no
one has ever charged this guy
with a crime
that is scary that's a scary situation
in america
not even because i think people ought to
be able to say whatever they want
not because i don't object to things
that he has said
but because of the rank hypocrisy and
double standard
anything that you can accuse that guy of
this
fringe 22 year old right winger who has
absolutely no power whatsoever who has
been as ostracized in society as you
possibly can be
without going to guantanamo bay anything
you can accuse him of
you can just as easily accuse the
mainstream
left of nick fuentes is racist
okay he's no more racist than mark
lamont hill
he's no more racist than ibrahim kendi
who make these blanket hideous
assertions about white people he's no
more racist than
virtually any mainstream liberal nick
fuentes is dangerous
yeah maybe he's no more dangerous than
the
the mainstream left which is abusing its
power tremendously
so much so that it can place people on
the no-fly list and utterly ostracize
them from society
without ever charging them with a crime
i'm i'm not in any way defending fuentes
and i'm not in any way
defending this kind of free speech
absolutist idea that you ought to be
able to say what you want without
consequences
i'm just i'm actually pointing out as a
tactical and practical matter
the way that this is such a disingenuous
argument
i do not think for one second that the
libs are enforcing
any kind of anti-racist standard any
anti-violence standard i don't think
that's it at all
i don't think that's it at all because i
think that they're perfectly fine when
when people on the left
make hideous racial remarks when people
on the left
not only threaten violence but commit
violence and defend violence like
the sitting vice president of the united
states kamala harris who used social
media platforms
to bail out violent rioters during the
blm riots i don't think the left has a
standard at all here so
that part of it goes away and by the way
i don't think the left
sees much of a distinction between
people like
nick fuentes and and any other
mainstream conservative
i don't think they make any distinction
at all this banning
of this this guy is not a matter of
principle it's a very cynical tactic
it's going to be used on the rest of us
and so my reaction to it is is really
not
reacting as though it were a question of
principle it's it's a question of
practical politics and tactics
what is this really really about
i think if the liberal establishment has
shown us anything
in the past few years even the past few
weeks
it's that they're not just after fringe
figures people who have been
marginalized to or
who are really out there and radical
they're after
mainstream right wingers people like
donald trump
people like tucker carlson very possibly
people like you
and me
the liberal establishment
has gone after tucker carlson through
the nsa which is
one that's no no such agency as it used
to be called it's one of the more
secretive agencies
of the federal government and tucker on
his show a couple of weeks ago
came out and he said i've gotten a tip
off that the nsa is spying on me
and they're planning to leak my
communications to the press
in an effort to take down this show and
then the nsa put out a non-denial denial
they put out a denial that they actually
didn't deny any of the things that
tucker there's very cleverly worded
fake denial and then what happened
tucker's communications get leaked to
the press
and they tried to pull the same russian
collusion nonsense that they pulled on
donald trump
also to no ultimate effect but but it
held him up for a long time
now andrew weissman is a former lawyer
with the department of justice he worked
on the mueller witch hunt he's pretty
familiar
with the way these sorts of operations
go down andrew weissman appeared on
msnbc
and i think he accidentally gave away
a little glimpse into the kind of
corruption that we're talking about at
the federal government take a listen see
if you can find out
where he gives it away you know if you
think about what carlson could have done
here
is he could have followed the same route
that
the new york times and other respected
journalists did
when they were incidentally
overheard and may have in fact
been not incidentally had their
call records uh obtained by the
department of justice they could have
gone to
the attorney general and tucker carlson
could have joined them to say
you know what i'm concerned about here
is not that there was incidental
collection
when i am calling a foreigner including
of course if you try and reach out to
vladimir putin you can pretty much uh be
sure that you're
going to be uh that high risk of being
intercepted he could have said look
there's a first amendment issue here and
i want to make sure that there are
safeguards at the department of justice
but he didn't take that route he did as
you said
and as frank pointed out he wanted to
use this really for his own purposes
and to so distrust which is is so
anti-american
it's so anti-american to question the
nsa
it's so anti-american to air
some of the corruption that's going on
in the federal government through a free
press that's so
anti-american is what the left believes
now
the trick here the the unwitting
admission i think
comes down to this question why would
tucker carlson go to the department of
justice
forget for a second the department of
justice has had a lot of scandals going
back to obama
going back to loretta lynch going who
meets on the tarmac with bill clinton
while
bill clinton's wife is under
investigation forget about
some of the abuses during the trump era
when the doj
was was going after the duly elected
president forget about that for a second
the nsa the national security agency has
a foreign intelligence mission
the doj has a domestic
law enforcement mission
why does the doj just have ready access
to all of the nsa records
why is it why are these two groups
apparently
synonymous why are they being conflated
well the reason for this
the reason for this simple enough answer
is that the doj or the
doj national security division
has some crossover with the nsa but it's
not supposed to just have simple access
like you just go in you log into a
computer okay well let's see what's
going on
with all of these countless records that
we've intercepted
the only reason they intercept the data
their argument for intercepting the data
is that it has to do with foreigners
the doj is going in the federal domestic
law enforcement agency
going into do oh there we go there's
tucker under the process
that andrew weissman is describing
apparently the doj just has
totally unlimited access to whatever the
nsa is capturing
right is it but i don't think is that
legal i don't i don't think that should
be illegal
now this the doj national security
division the doj
nsd is a relatively recent creation of
the federal government it was created in
2005 with
the reauthorization of the patriot act
and it has
access to the nsa data don't forget the
nsa just gathering
tons and tons of data and sometimes
they'll say well occasionally you might
be
accidentally intercepted but only if
you're talking in some way to a
foreigner this is the same bogus excuse
that they used for spying on the trump
campaign
so the the doj national security
division has access to the nsa data
and crucially it is not subject to the
doj inspector general so
no oversight at all obviously totally
wide open for abuse
so and then andrew weissman goes on the
show and he says come on tucker should
have just trusted the government don't
worry the government that has
virtually unlimited power to spy on any
american citizen
that is obviously being used for
domestic surveillance purposes of
political dissidence
even very mainstream dissidents like
tucker carlson yeah just go to the doj
just trust the doj what could go wrong
what could go wrong some more evidence
that our federal law enforcement has
been
rotted out from the core fbi tweets out
just this weekend
that you should rat on your family if
you think they're becoming politically
extreme
quote family members and peers are often
best positioned to witness signs of
mobilization to violence
help prevent homegrown violent extremism
visit blah blah blah website to to learn
how to spot suspicious
behaviors and report them to the fbi
hashtag national security
this is the sort of thing that you read
about in dystopian
novels this is the sort of thing that
you read about
in communist china and yet this sort of
thing is not only going on
in the united states it's being
encouraged by
the most mainstream federal law
enforcement agencies
rat on your family rat on your family
if you think that your family are they
wearing too many maga hats
is your does your family own any
american flags that could be a sign of
extremism
go make sure you rat them out to the
feds
we talk a lot about the attack on the
family from the radical cultural right
i'm sorry from the radical cultural left
you know the
the weird sexual revolution stuff but
there are attacks on the family that go
on from
the government even from institutions
that were once considered somewhat
right-wing right i'm talking about the
fbi and other other groups
they're going in and saying you need to
divvy up your family you need to have a
closer relationship with the federal
government than you do with your mother
and your father and your brother
and your the rest of your family and
speaking of priorities
at the fbi this is my favorite one this
is just the little
cherry on top of the sunday of federal
law enforcement corruption
the fbi you know they're doing a really
bang-up job
to to stop the violent insurrection
the coup d'etat oh my gosh the
constitution hung in the balance
in january of 2021 when some guy with
horns danced on a desk at the capitol
when that other smiling guy took
pelosi's lecture and you know the
violent it was nearly a revolution
forget about the blm riots where they
burned down half the country you know
forget about that for like months and
months at a time burn down government
buildings
private forget about that no no the horn
guy that that was
that was the coup d'etat
at the fbi doing a lot to try to throw
these people in prison
who trespassed at the capitol meanwhile
law enforcement is letting
a huge portion of the blm riders
completely off the hook
but the guys who entered the capital big
problem so
the fbi seized piece of evidence from
pennsylvania man who was indicted last
month for his role in the insurrection
the piece of evidence was a logo uh logo
a lego replica
of the capital big government building
and
lego came out with a lego version of the
capital the daily beast reported
robert morse 27 years old is accused of
leading fellow rioters
in what prosecutors say was one of the
most intense and prolonged clashes with
officers
on january 6th don't forget by the way
they completely lied to us about
officers being killed in the riot just
didn't happen even the new york times
later had to admit that it didn't happen
they're still insinuating it but they
can't state it outright because it's a
lie
this is according to the daily beast
prosecutors didn't say whether morse
used his toy to help plan the capital
insurrection
but obviously they had to take it as
evidence now
however turns out that
the guy didn't even build the lego set
so not only did he not
did he not use the lego toy of the
capitol as a way to plan
oh this is we're going to enter here
through this block
we're going to make a turn at this no he
didn't even open it up
it was just in the box he didn't even
build it this now
quote in original detention memoranda
the undersigned stated that law
enforcement found a fully constructed
u.s capital lego set that statement
appears to be inaccurate the lego set
was in a box and not fully constructed
at the time of the search
this according to the new filing
this is to me the worrisome thing this
is why
i think uh even some radical right
winger being kicked off of twitter
is a is a worrisome move
the most radical fringy ostracized
low influence right wing
is being treated as the terrorist threat
to the country
and the things that they are doing are
no worse
and often not even close to as bad as
what the mainstream left is doing i
guess the perfect example of this is the
difference
between the capital riot which we're
told is the worst event that ever
happens worse than pearl harbor it's
worse than 911
versus the blm riots which actually
killed many
many people and destroyed countless
homes and stores and burned down
multiple cities for months and months at
a time
and that we're told is a mostly peaceful
protest
some radical right-wing guy who's been
ostracized who has a very small
following relatively
says odious and offensive things
on race and sex and whatever we are told
this is the greatest threat we need to
kick him out of the society
mark lamont hill says things that are
just as odious if not more odious
he has a program he hasn't got a twitter
feed
ibram kendi has given awards
undeservedly so
that is the fear here there is no
standard this is not it's not even
it's not even that it's hypocrite
there's a meme going around
it's not even that it's hypocrisy it's a
hierarchy
the leftist agenda prioritized
any sort of conservative agenda
ostracized
delegitimized and censored
the government is really intruding into
your family
which we'll get to in a second first
though you know dan is going to be
talking today but have foreigners
love the american flag apparently much
more than americans do he's going to be
talking about these pro-freedom
demonstrations down in cuba
you can also read about this in his new
book the authoritarian moment
you can arm yourself with the knowledge
you need to shut down america's tyrants
says ben in the authoritarian moment
which is now available for pre-order at
amazon barnes and noble or any other
major bookseller it's a great book to
pre-order
after you order speechless controlling
words controlling minds it's also great
because ben
named his book after my future campaign
slogan
knowles 2028 the authoritarian moment so
go
go check out his book today we'll be
right back with a lot more
the government is intruding into your
family and it's not just the feds
telling little johnny to rat on his
parents in a tweet though they are doing
that as well
they are also using the schools to go in
and try to
upend traditional family dynamics and
the traditional family structure
the chicago public school system
not considered the premier educational
institution in the country
the chicago public school system is now
giving condoms to 10 year olds
schools that teach fifth grade and up
must now maintain a
condom availability program as part of
an expanded vision of sexual health
education
that means all but a dozen uh which will
a dozen schools which enroll only
younger grades of the more than
600 chicago public school schools will
have condoms according to the
top doctor employed by the chicago
public school system
young people have the right to accurate
and clear information to make healthy
decisions and they need access to
resources to protect their health and
the health of others
as they make and act on those decisions
so you're seeing another another real
confusing statement one it's unclear why
a physician would have any particular
expertise on sexual ethics and morality
why he is being considered the expert
that would be a realm traditionally
reserved for
priests for ethicists for moral
philosophers for theologians and for
parents
but now all those people have been
pushed to the fringes of society and had
their political power taken away
and all the power is going to the
priests the high priests of secular
progressivism
also known as physicians so this
physician says yes it's very important
for health
that 10 year olds have condoms
elementary schools will be given 250
condoms
high schools many of which already have
the condoms will be given 1 000 condoms
so i'm glad
i'm glad that the elementary schools are
only going to be given
250 condoms because they're they're
assuming that 10 year olds are only
having sex or younger by the way are
only having sex
a quarter of the time that the high
school students are this is really sick
stuff now
one of the arguments here is that uh
you know if you if you give condoms out
to these kids
that that's not to encourage them to
have it won't encourage them to have sex
now of course it will
the way the way these things work is if
you make things easier you will get
more of that thing if you make certain
behavior easier you will get more
of that behavior the experts
love this kind of stuff the parents
don't love this kind of stuff and the
glimmer of hope i have here is all these
parents
who have shown up to the school boards
to protest critical race theory or
radical gender theory they're going out
and they're saying i don't care what you
insane eggheads are thinking with your
radical theories
we don't care we don't care how preening
and sneering you are
we are going to take back our kids
education you are now seeing a move
by some on the right to run school board
candidates the left has been very good
at running school board candidates local
political races
the right has been very bad at that but
now you're seeing that
change a little bit so one hopes that
that we can keep this kind of thing up
because if you are defending giving out
taxpayer-funded condoms to ten-year-olds
something has seriously gone wrong
with your political philosophy and
speaking of
creepy sex stuff in kids you know how
much i hate to say i told you so you
know i hate it
i hate it pains me to say i told you so
but i have to do it a lot because i tell
you so a lot
the right has has warned that as you
mainstream
all this kind of creepy weird sexual
revolution stuff
you are going to get more and more
deviant more and more
perverse behavior and some of it's going
to involve kids
and what did the left say they said oh
you're making that slippery slope
argument again oh
come on give me a break and the problem
with the slippery slope
criticism here is that the right
winger's objections have
been proven correct 100 of the time this
we are so far
down the slippery slope now you think
you can't go any further but actually it
turns out you can
a london library sparked a little bit of
backlash thankfully
after hiring recently an
anti-racist carnival troop with a
performer who dressed up as a monkey
a monkey in a rainbow monkey costume
with a gigantic
plastic phallus hanging between his legs
for a children's reading event the
monkey
had a giant plastic sex toy
in the shape of a phallus hanging
between his rainbow clothing
that he swung around for children at a
library
the red bridge central library
in the united kingdom hosted a
performance from the mandinga
arts carnival group anti-racist sexual
revolutionary
video footage on social media shows the
guy with the giant
floppy creepy mock genitalia this is
part of the summer reading challenge
in partnership with the world wildlife
fund for a very special nature themed
challenge
that will inspire you to stand up for
the planet so they said
i l i i think it would be good in the
united kingdom and the united states
it's not long before this craziness
comes here
i think it would be good to ban this
sort of stuff to not permit it
to limit the free marketplace of ideas
to exclude
rainbow monkeys with sex toys between
their legs dancing for kids i think that
would be
i don't think that the mandinga giant
dancing rainbow monkey sex toy group is
one of the quote
blessings of liberty as some erstwhile
conservative commentators have suggested
i don't think this is what the founding
fathers had in mind i don't think that
there is a first amendment protection
for flopping sex toys around for little
children
i really like the idea of standards and
it worries me that people
are pretending to get exercised about
some radical right wingers
who have relatively small followings who
have relatively
little influence in the country and they
make a big deal and they cut them off
from all aspects of society
when this kind of stuff is not only
permitted
but celebrated encouraged and subsidized
by taxpayers in this case
in the united kingdom but we've seen
lots of similar things here in the
united states
and there's all of the evidence pointing
that it will only get worse that's a big
problem that's i think something we
should focus on i was
riding in an uber yesterday i sound like
i'm starting a tom
thomas friedman column at the new york
times i was riding in an uber in beirut
and i heard no i was riding in an uber
in nashville yesterday
and the driver wanted to put on npr
and they're putting on npr and that
stupid program that i can't stand
wait wait don't tell me you know all
these sort of very pretentious shows on
npr
that allow suburban people to feel like
they're really intelligent
national public radio which you and i
pay for by the way national public radio
comes on and they have a little they
have a little news
blurb at the beginning of it and they've
got that very very npr kind of voice and
it's all very
moderate and just very intelligent very
calm and this is the way that the elite
people listen
and they talk and we were told that cpac
the conservative political action
conference took place yesterday in texas
and the republicans at cpac focused more
on their culture war obsessions that
have come to define the republican party
for the past several years i'm
jane smith at npr now here is your
program wait wait don't tell me
and i said hold on that was very calm
and sort of put me into a trance and
i know it's very moderate and very
intelligent but did you just say
did you just say that republicans
are the ones pushing the culture war
obsessions
you're telling me you're telling me that
the left in this country can go out
smear the majority of the country
white people as racists worse than you
can be called in america
can go out and teach three-year-old boys
that they're actually little girls
can permit grown adult men to go into
the women's changing room
can radically redefine marriage can kill
a million babies a year through abortion
can bring transvestites some of whom are
convicted
sex offenders into public libraries to
twerk for children
and we conservatives are the ones
pushing the culture war
you can actually say that with a
straight face on npr and i think a lot
of
people believe it i think a lot if i if
i
were politically not very aware and
i were just you know a suburban woman
just trying to
seem intelligent just trying to be part
of the mainstream and i turned on
i would be very taken with the view of
the world being pushed by npr
but it is so so insane it is so
so radical and it expresses the views of
the liberal establishment that has
all of the power in the country
i think that's where the threat really
lies okay i think
the threat of the radical right-wing
fringe extreme that has no power i think
that is
a phantom menace i think that is not i
think that is a distraction
to lure you away from where the threats
actually
reside because by the way i think the
majority of americans
support conservative points of view on a
whole lot of issues
definitely on all this creepy weird sex
stuff definitely on all the insane race
stuff coming from the left
but but on other issues as well think
about immigration
the majority of americans want to
drastically reduce immigration majority
of them that includes democrats that
includes
independents they want to drastically
reduce immigration according to a
harvard-harris poll legal and illegal
dramatically and yet the entire
establishment
the democrats and many republicans want
effectively open borders
isn't that weird how is i thought this
was a democratic republic
i thought that our representatives were
supposed to represent
the wishes of the people and yet for
decades and decades
they haven't because
power in this country does not lie with
the people quite as much as you would
believe
from reading the constitution how about
voter id laws there was a poll just came
out
this was a poll that was commissioned by
the republican national committee and it
was conducted by kellyanne conway
uh so you know obviously those are
right-wing organizations relatively
right-wing organizations
but nevertheless there's no reason to
doubt that this poll was conducted with
some sort of rigor
paul finds that 78 percent of voters
surveyed said that in addition to
stronger voter id laws
they also support signature verification
chain of custody controls
bipartisan observers overseeing counting
and cleaning up the voter rolls
according to this poll 71 said they
don't think ballots should be accepted
after the election day
and 87 percent full 87 are against
ballot harvesting
and if you don't believe this poll just
keep in mind that many many many other
polls
have backed up these results so
all the stuff that the democrats did in
terms of election laws
using covet as an excuse the vast
majority of americans oppose
and yet they get away with it why
because the broadly conservative views
of the american people
are not represented in our government
that's why
that's why and we are told that those
conservative views
the mega the trump supporters the coup
d'etat the radical right
we are told that they are the grave
threat to our country well it looks like
their views are pretty popular it looks
like actually your
insane radical views on the left in the
liberal establishment
those are very unpopular maybe that's
why the the establishment needs to clamp
down
so hard maybe that's why they let blm
off the hook
but the horn guy and the guy who took
pelosi's elector and that's why they're
going to rot in prison how about on the
border how about on immigration
only one in four democrats
agree with joe biden that there is no
border crisis this according to a poll
from the economist and yougov
so this is more of a left-leaning group
only one of every four registered
democrats agree with biden
that there is not a border crisis 27
percent
49 of registered democrats say that the
border
represents a national crisis 24 say
they're not sure
so roughly twice as many people believe
that it is a crisis among registered
democrats
as believed that it is not a crisis
forget republicans for a second
and yet and yet nothing is going to
happen
because the democratic base the
democratic voters are useful idiots for
the ruling establishment for the regime
but even their views are not being
represented
speaking of our national borders there
is some
real horrifying political radicalism
going on in america's hat our neighbors
to the north up in canada
churches being burned to the ground
across the country
you probably haven't heard very much
about that in the mainstream press
certainly not here in the united states
we hear that the church is an oppressor
we hear
that the the right wing
is the big threat and yet it's radical
leftist groups
attacking the church
in canada several
churches in canada have been burned some
completely destroyed
the reason for this ostensibly is
because there was the discovery of
hundreds of unmarked indigenous graves
in residential schools in saskatchewan
manitoba and british columbia
so there was this program to canadianize
some of the indigenous
people there and there were these
residential schools and they found
some what were what are being portrayed
in the media is
mass graves unmarked graves
but but there's no evidence
that this is the hiding of a genocide or
anything like that in fact in
in a number of cases the alleged
unmarked graves which
they just had the markers wiped away
everyone knew there were graveyards
there it's just that
over time the the markers have
disappeared or eroded
and were there abuses at these schools i
suppose so but there were abuses at
all schools around the entire
anglosphere so it's not as though this
native indigenous people are being
singled out for abuse and is it because
people today are just furious about the
treatment no i don't think it's because
they hate
the church now some indigenous people
are pushing back against this jesse
allen who's an assistant pentagon
pentecostal minister in canada is
pushing back and saying hey
pro-indigenous groups stop burning down
the churches my name is jesse allen i'm
a 60 scoop survivor and then daughter of
a residential school survivor
we're here basically to ask people to
basically quit burning down churches
we're concerned about the burning and
defacing of churches bringing more
strife depression anxiety to those
already in pain in mourning
former survivors of kansas central
schools are triggered by the sight of
burning and defaced churches
it also brings up former traumatic
feelings of violence and threats to
their lives
this is also putting further division
between kansas indigenous people and the
rest of canadian society
we're asking for people are setting
these fires to stop now we understand
some people believe that they're
standing in solidarity with us
indigenous people as we find more graves
across canada
burning down churches is not in
solidarity less indigenous people as i
said we do not destroy people's places
of worship
well said i'm really glad that she said
this sort of thing
i was speaking to lauren southern who's
canadian commentator now she lives in
australia
she said in many cases the people
burning down the churches are not
indigenous people they're
white leftists who are burning them down
on behalf
allegedly of the indigenous people
you're not going to hear a whole lot
about this problem but you rarely heard
about the churches being burned down
around france and the rest of europe
the attacks during the blm summer on
very important historic churches in the
united states
you don't hear about that we're told the
real threat
comes from the theocratic right-wing
authoritarians why how
what are they doing they're wearing horn
hats in the capitol
they're sending tweets some sometimes
legitimately offensive things i'm not
even denying that
and what's going on on the left burning
down burning down churches in canada
burning down
businesses churches government buildings
in the united states
taking away people's rights spying
on americans that to me that's the real
threat
call me crazy that's the real threat now
there is some good news i don't want to
leave you
just bereft of good news there is some
good news on this standards front
there's a school
in sullivan county uh that is
firing a teacher for his radical leftist
views
or really because he wouldn't present
anything other than his radical leftist
view
the sullivan county board of education
voted six to one
to to fire this teacher matthew han
who was a ten-year teacher he was
accused of insubordination and repeated
unprofessional conduct
because he gave multiple assignments
focusing on white privilege
but failed to present opposing points of
view in particular he
assigns the writing of truly one of the
most overrated
writers working today a man named tom
nehesi coates
who is uh broadly of this opinion that
you know whiteness and evils of white
supremacy pervade everything and it's
the greatest threat
and whether or not he said all white
people are racist in those explicit
terms that would seem to be the
implication of his writing
so this guy han taught a class called
contemporary issues he coached baseball
at the school
he received a letter of reprimand after
having students read this radical
leftist writer but not reading any
alternate viewpoints alternative
viewpoints he refused to do anything
about it
and now he's fired that's good i'm glad
i'm so glad if academic freedom means
anything at all
it means the ability of scholars to
pursue their own studies it does not
mean that teachers have the right to
teach whatever they want they
obviously do not no one would tolerate a
nazi going in and teaching a sociology
class
and yet we all tolerate communists going
in and teaching sociology class or
teaching
political science or teaching history or
teaching
everything teaching math teaching
everything we do and we should not
tolerate that
we're all told the big threat to the
country comes from the nazis
how many nazis are there there's i think
there's like seven nazis in the country
and i think six of them are feds
i think they're they're all they're all
kind of working for the fbi spying on
one another i don't think it's
effectively a completely contrived
threat
but i do think there are self-described
communists in the country that
the founders of black lives matter
describe themselves as trained marxists
and openly supported communist
politicians
that seems like a threat to me the
anarchists who burn down a lot of the
country
that seems like a real threat to me and
yet those guys get blue check marks and
those guys get to
fly on airplanes and those guys get to
do whatever they want those guys get
macarthur genius grants for goodness
sakes those guys get
awards and positions of power and
influence
maybe maybe the right should consider
exercising power as well i'm i'm really
pleased to see that the school board has
come out
and and said no sorry teacher you're out
of here
this teacher's got to go
you're seeing this we don't have time to
get to it today but you're seeing this
especially on the public health front
the public health apparatus which you
know has been leading the charge at the
political power grab for the past year
the well this public health front is
keeping its power there were some people
who believed before the election that
okay
you know day after the election kovid's
going to go away biden will solve it
they'll let us all go back to normal
and i thought that early on but then i
realized you know a couple months before
the election i said oh wait a second
people don't give back power when they
get it
this is probably going to go on for a
long time now we're hearing about the
delta variant the lambda variant the the
this variant of that variant and we are
now being told
that the biden administration is going
to send thugs door to door to get you
vaccinated we're being told
by top medical advisors in the country
they're hideous perverse sort of vision
of
of medical care but they're coming out
and saying they need to make life really
hard for unvaccinated
people we'll get to that tomorrow
they're going to have to make it really
hard for unvaccinated people because
they've got the power and they're going
to shut down
the people without the power and they're
going to gaslight us into telling us
that the people without any power
whatsoever they're the real they're the
real threat to the country i'm michael
knowles this michael knowles shall see
you tomorrow
[Music]
the michael knowles show is produced by
ben davies executive producer jeremy
boary
our technical director is austin stevens
supervising producers
mathis glover and robert sterling
production manager
pavel vadofsky editor and associate
producer
danny d'amico audio mixer mike coramina
hair and makeup by nika geneva and
production coordinator
mckenna waters the michael knowles show
is a daily wire production
copyright daily wire 2021 on the mat
wall show we talk about the things that
matter real issues that affect you your
family our country not just politics but
culture faith current events
all the fundamentals if they matter to
you come check out the show